[Music]
michael
is in oklahoma hey michael how are you
hi mr ramsey i'm doing better than i
deserve better still
just the same sir how can we help
um well i i've been listening to you
uh you know your little mini photos on
youtube for the past
uh about two months um came a little
late to me
um i'm 26. the uh
in february i started looking for a
vehicle a more dependable vehicle
and my brother's a car salesman um yeah
i went there with a budget
and uh came out with a car
yeah yeah i found a truck i like
it was outside my budget i left i come
back the next day
my dad and brother have a surprise for
me they went ahead and got it
and my dad did it under his
you know took a loan under his name and
so now i'm obligated to pay it
and uh it's way out of it's 200 over
what my budget was originally and i'm
it's making me bleed like a pig yeah
well thanks dad wow uh
so when you're selling it
and then you know i i want to sell it i
think that's what i need to do
yeah it came from a place of love
and i think he wanted me in a nicer
vehicle um
but it's it it's just not working out
for me you know
okay the uh
so you know that's the answer is to sell
it
and uh i i had one more question if you
have time real quick
um i'm a diesel mechanic here in
in oklahoma and uh
are you there mystery yeah yeah we're
here and yeah go ahead okay sorry guys
and uh i'm working for uh my boss
and i've been working for him going on
two years and uh
you know haven't had a pay raise so i'm
making twelve dollars an hour as a
diesel mechanic
and uh how do i approach him about
you know that
yeah have you got any of the
certifications as a diesel mechanic or
you just been working there with him
no uh i was in the navy previously i was
an aviation structural mechanic
and before that i went through in high
school and uh
went through vo-tech and got all my
sounds awfully cheap twelve dollars an
hour
like way cheap and
uh what's that i mean i mean i think i
know these guys making 60 or 80 grand
with what you're doing don't you uh
yeah the ones out in the oil field are
making a lot of money they're making
more than that
no off yeah but i'm talking about just a
straight up diesel mechanic
you know plus or minus some overtime
anywhere from 60 to 90 is the ones we're
running into
michael do you have any uh openings have
you done any research on other
availabilities
in that in that market a bunch of
indeed and um you know i
there's there's openings
um it's uh it's i just stay so busy
that in my budget is so tight that if i
take a day off
you know i'm shooting myself in the foot
so i if
it's kind of like uh i can't afford to
do it but i can't afford not to do it
and uh okay have you investigated what
the openings are paying michael
uh i mean they're starting out at 15 an
hour you know
so i mean they're they're starting out
more than where you know which is still
low that's still low yeah
i would say this buddy here's the thing
we got to get your confidence back so
first of all
let's get rid of this truck uh let's get
go find out exactly what the payoff is
for
a 30 day period uh go look up on kelly
blue book
get intentional about getting this thing
out of the life uh go ahead and have the
conversation with your dad and let him
know
hey this is not something you can afford
point blank and don't go backwards there
uh the other thing i do is i'd go sit
down with your employer let's be adults
be straight
and talk about hey this is where i am
this is what i'm striving to do
what more do i need to show you what can
i do but dave i think he's got it here's
four p
here's four job offers in the open
market that pay 15 to 20
an hour yeah and you're paying me 12.
and i'm not threatening you i'm just
saying what have i got to do to be worth
that to you
uh so because i don't really want to
look elsewhere
boom and if someone comes in and sits
down with me as the owner of this
company and says hey
you know i do this for you and
there's a whole lot of people paying a
lot more than that um
i mean i may say well you probably ought
to go talk to them or i might say
uh gosh i guess i'm underpaying let's
look at it right
you know and we'll do a little
compensation study we do regular
compensation studies around here but a
lot of small businesses don't do that
and they just overlook it
and then they look up and they lose
somebody good because they didn't have a
conversation well and dave the other
side of it is is that you have the
person that's on the team
that's having this feeling that never
outwardly communicates it so they never
give the person a chance but don't bring
don't come in and say i think i'm worth
more money no
or demanding don't be belligerent but
come in and go hey look here's three
things in the paper right
that are paying 15 and here's one that's
17. here's one that's 20.
and you know this is what's out there
and it just feels like 12 is not the
market anymore
and i tell me what i'm doing wrong that
or what i need to do more to get to be
worth
what those are paying because i don't
really want to answer any of these ads i
like being here
boom and that's a you know somebody does
that with me as the employer i don't
they don't get any shame from me they go
it may be a wake-up call it might be i
go you know what we just don't have it
in the budget to do that if you can get
that you probably ought to go do it
that's right that's what's good for you
i might i've told people that too
but uh and you might hear that he might
be going 12 dollars it dude
um and then but at least you can get it
out there and you that's how you
approach them you approach them with
evidence and with humility
and with open communication and then
that
no and if an employer does not react
well to those things
uh and and is inappropriate or angry or
something then that's means they're a
jerk
yeah it doesn't mean you did it wrong
but let's get your headspace back
because so many people will play this
over and over in their head
instead of verbalizing it outward uh be
proactive